[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got a very special treat
for you today i've got isaiah here with
me this is his second time on the
podcast thank you so much for doing this
again sir
man so glad to be back it's been a long
time there's a long time coming glad to
see you pump
absolutely so uh we're jumping on today
because last night we were in clubhouse
uh and we were in a room it was me you
uh delaying chris lyons chris dixon from
andreas and horowitz
uh there was meek mill mike novogratz uh
just a whole host of people in there
and uh at one point you took the mic and
uh
you took over man it was absolutely
amazing to watch uh
so basically i just want to kind of go
through uh how you're thinking about
bitcoin
um and uh you know kind of talk through
some of the nuances that you spoke about
last night
before we do that let's start with just
your background kind of tell us where
you grew up
what you've done career-wise uh before
you wrote the book and then tell us a
little bit about
uh the book series uh bitcoin about
black america
so yes uh my name is isaiah jackson and
i'm originally from charlotte north
carolina
and uh you know charlotte is one of the
biggest banking cities
in the world so if you know anything
about that uh you know everybody here
has a banking
aunt or uncle or a cousin and one of the
best parts about
that was i grew up thinking that that
was of course you know the entire
financial center but my background is uh
i went to nc state from college
uh went there for uh computer science
and then got into i.t
uh at first i was a teacher i taught
computer science and then i got into the
i.t world so i had a pretty solid tech
background
um being uh it analyst and software
developer but
when i saw bitcoin in 2013 um that sort
of
put the two together uh again like i
said i have people in my family on the
financial side in the take side when
bitcoin came it's the purest
form of fintech uh it's fintech and it's
purest form so when that came about
um one of the things that it piqued my
interest was of course
i could make money from it but also too
there were problems in computer science
that were
finally solved like byzantine uh the
byzantine
generals problem was finally solved so
that's one of the things that that
peaked my interest but
i love the fact that uh you know back
then people thought it was for drug
dealers they thought it was scammers for
multi-level marketing and i got
you know my own family members and
friends were like what are you doing man
what is this bitcoin thing you're
talking about
and you know my background uh before
bitcoin
was always sort of defiant sort of first
first to do something so i think i was
right at home when i found bitcoin
and before i wrote bitcoin in black
america i had the gentleman of crypto
show which is still going daily one of
the longest runner shows in the industry
uh and also i have i've also written
three bitcoin starter guides before
bitcoin and black america came out so
i've done a lot traveled around the
country
speaking with people uh you know going
to up and down 85
driving driving to people's houses just
to be laughed at speaking to financial
groups who
were looking me up and down like who is
this 25 26 year old kid telling me i
don't know what i'm talking about
uh you know because i used to i used to
go there i said hey gold
who cares about gold and you know i
should make bets i would say hey i bet
you want bitcoin it'll be past gold's
market cap
and they would never go for it so i've
been through it a lot and it's just good
to see that once the book came out
i was able to package those those
experiences and that knowledge
and able to produce it and give it to
the people and at this point with the
second version coming out i think we're
getting to a point now
where that knowledge base is building
and we have a solid foundation
in my community and the broader
community as well absolutely
and what's so fascinating i think as
i've gotten to know you and kind of
seeing a lot of the content you've put
out is
you really are focused on a community
that doesn't get
spoken about almost at all really when
it comes to a bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies so most people will
talk about wall street uh or they'll
talk about
um kind of the developing world right
those are the two main things people say
oh the adoption is happening
uh in those two places but you're really
talking about
what is essentially a developing um
sector of the us economy right in terms
of black america
and uh maybe let's start with just some
of the problems that you see
uh with that community interacting with
the legacy banking system like some of
the stories you've told me
uh were very very eye-opening and
frankly shocking
knowing that hey this stuff happens
right here in the united states so maybe
help people understand just like what
the problems are
and some of the obstacles uh with the
legacy system are
so bitcoin went past 40 000
we saw all the hype and what i like to
do whenever we see this boy run hype is
take a step back
remember while we're here and i remember
why i was here i remember why it
intrigued me
i remember reading the white paper and
distinctly thinking to myself
this is perfect the people finally have
a chance we at least have a shot you
know
and it was more of a shock so to say
back then now i think it's a foregone
conclusion that we can actually
develop and the reason i thought you
know in the black community we would
have a shot was is because
traditionally or historically what we
have seen we have seen well
just semantics taken out of our
community uh through laws through
different practices
uh some of the banking practices like
you just said that have been very
egregious uh
including in the book i have all of my
examples from 2012
up to now so it's not like this is i'm
talking about a long time ago
before civil rights we're talking about
recently and they've settled disputes
uh that have stated that black americans
were given higher interest rates on
loans
uh they've settled disputes for racial
discrimination for hiring black
candidates in the financial market
we've also seen the racial
discrimination suits in the tech world
where you've seen
black people not able to work in the
c-suites where most of black
employees are at the base level so we've
seen this across the board the problem
is
i'm not one to complain i'm just looking
for the solution and i think a solution
to that
is something like bitcoin where if you
can
free your money you can also free your
industry and free your community
and in the black community all we're
looking for nobody i know is looking for
a handout
nobody wants you to give us anything we
just want the freedom to be able to
explore
and the things i've seen historically is
that
we don't really have any choice but to
to find another option at the very least
for leverage
um when you cut have any type of
business deal anybody will tell you
if you don't have any leverage there's
no reason to show up and i think that's
what the problem
black people running into is that we're
coming to politicians we're coming to
people saying hey
we want this to be done in our
communities but we're not
we don't have any leverage we the
violent part of it that's not going to
work we saw these guys storm capitol
hill
and nothing got done joe biden's still
gonna get sworn in so you have to
go for the money aspect of it if you can
say we will take our wealth out of this
system
we will move it to a better system like
bitcoin if we're not respected
at the very least you'll have the seat
at the table that you need the voice
that you need to have leverage to say
you you need to either change your
practices or will leave
that is how you flex your power and
that's only possible when you can
actually have a plan b like bitcoin so
because of the historical
nature of the financial markets in the
u.s and the emerging markets of black
people
coinbase just did a a uh a poll 75
percent of black people who were polls
said they
would buy crypto that's that's also
compared to
the least or smallest demographic that
isn't crypto so you have a perfect storm
of people who want to learn
but are undereducated you put that
together and that's why i do what i do
because
this is a booming market especially in
the us and also the third biggest
trading country nigeria
uh black brothers and sisters across
across the water
i mean there's a lot of family members i
know that are nigerian they have
family members back there this is not
just here it's international so this is
some
something that i definitely want to
tackle and i'm glad that we're actually
having this discussion
finally yeah what's so fascinating to me
is this idea of uh
you can protest there's a violent uh
path to pursue or there's this uh kind
of financial money path
and as you were talking what it reminded
me of is i think you know the jay-z's of
the world the drakes the kanye's
they really figured this out over the
last kind of two decades or so
kind of pay me in equity if i get enough
money i can have a seat at the table if
i own the actual businesses i can have a
seat at the table
and so that required you know immense
effort
and frankly some level of heroic
accomplishment to end up becoming a
billionaire or
getting enough capital to actually own
some of these businesses
but they were successful in the path
that they chose
i think really what kind of what you're
saying is like look right you know
overall strategy of hey you got to take
the money path but you may not have to
become a billionaire to be able to do it
right
there's this kind of easier path for the
everyday person to pursue
and so help understand a little bit just
in terms of some of those issues like
one thing you mentioned last night that
just blew me away
uh was the uh higher percentage of black
americans who will walk in for
a loan and not get it or they'll get the
loan
but they have a higher interest rate
versus a white counterpart and so
like how pervasive is that issue and
then we'll talk about how a
decentralized kind of digital world can
solve a lot of those problems
yes so those issues have subsided but
they do still exist and
one sector that we see it the most is in
the business world
uh in the business world you know a lot
of times there are certain factors that
will get you business loans
however not just with uh with retail
banks but vcs
only one percent or less than one
percent of vc money goes towards black
home businesses whether it's perception
of
money management whether that's the
historical perception that
you know tech companies can't be run by
black people and become prosperous
whatever it is uh that is those are the
facts
and from a data standpoint when you see
that you have to understand that
usually that is a result of things that
were put in place before so
you have an industry where you have the
same sort of uh loop
of money going right back to the same
people and if their network is
mostly white which most people hang with
people in their industry that's what
you're gonna get over and over
bitcoin releases that so now you can
invest anybody around the world
technically um
using a free money system and i think
that that is something that
should be spoken for as far as the
barrier to entry because
when we talk about the banking system
and trying to get money here and trying
to get
all that is going through a third party
and going through an entity that has
human error do you want to choose humans
or do you want to choose math
and and technology choose math and
technology is built into the code for
bitcoin
you have the ability to take control so
why not do that and
uh we don't have to worry about someone
sitting across from you and judging you
based on whatever factors
doesn't matter uh decentralized finance
where that comes in
is that for the first time ever the only
thing you need is the collateral that's
all it should be it shouldn't be
what zip code you are what do you need
it for kyc
that's a debate we can have later
shouldn't even matter it should really
be
if you have the collateral here's the
cash if you pay it back here's back your
collateral that's it
very simple process but there's all
these steps in between to convoluted but
now that it is possible
the black community can usually or you
know usually
you can't do this but now we can
actually use bitcoin as collateral
get cash loans for businesses build
those small businesses at a time
where a lot of businesses are decimated
they're looking for a way out
after a lot of the covet shutdowns and
in the black community i can't save
everybody but you can save yourself
and if there's a way for you to win that
is the best thing you can do for the
black
community is to build yourself up be
self-sovereign be self-sufficient
and use something like decentralized
finance to do that bitcoin
solves that problem and the community as
a whole wins
when individually you can build yourself
up yeah
kind of pulling on this a little bit
more um in the decentralized finance
world whether it's on bitcoin somewhere
else
forget you know kind of where it ends up
being successful but just the idea of
decentralized finance
really what you're talking about here is
it doesn't matter who you are what
language
you speak what uh nationality you are
what your skin color is
uh your education level none of that
stuff matters if you've got you know
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
bitcoin and you need a twenty thousand
dollar loan you can post that hundred
thousand dollars of bitcoin
and these decentralized protocols just
recognized somebody gave me a hundred
thousand dollars worth of bitcoin here's
your twenty thousand dollars of a stable
coin or us dollars or whatever it is
and so it sounds like really what you're
talking about is a
technology uh and a financial system
that's technology enabled
that is almost built in a way that
protects itself
from human error human bias and a lot of
the issues that we see in the legacy
world right
absolutely or even if those things enter
into the space
it's quickly shut down because we are
great at self-regulating in the crypto
market
as you've seen uh we're some of the best
self-regulators they are because we know
building from scratch we can't afford to
have scammers and
you know human error trying to mess it
up or some somebody trying to
to change what bitcoin or what crypto is
meant for so
uh we do a great job of that and in my
opinion
uh i i love the fact that our industry
we don't care what type of human enters
into it you have to prove yourself in
the crypto market
i mean as you know we laugh at
billionaires uh warren buffett gets
criticized
all the time you know people say have
fun staying poor to mark cuban like what
you know i mean i love it i mean even
though it's you know
pretty pretty crazy people have to
remember that's where we started that is
what this was built on and these crazy
random people over the internet somehow
built a financial industry so it broke
down the mindset that
you need this government to tell you
this is your money you need some sort of
regulatory body to tell you this is how
you can spend it
all that has gone out the window we have
the richest man in the world smoking
weed on joe rogan
and posting dogecoin memes it's over
people like your thought process of what
the financial industry is is over so
i love that that exists and i think the
black community is perfect for that
because you can be yourself
i think that's what a lot of black
people do not think about the financial
industry they think of suit tai
uh a guy with a briefcase he comes with
this index fund jibber jabber
talk i don't understand which as you
know a lot of times the financial
industry was built that way
it was built to be very confusing so you
just hand it off to a financial manager
take your ten percent i don't even want
to talk about it this
industry bitcoin is opposite everybody i
know will teach you i mean you can ask
anybody they'll teach you at least the
beginning to start
they'll point you in the right direction
they'll build a whole website lock
jamison lop has a whole website
he can learn everything at one time
myself i'll write books i don't work for
bitcoin
there's no bitcoin company this is the
only industry where that happens and i
think the best shop the black community
has is in an industry like this
yeah i could not agree more uh one of
the comments that you've made recently
that i absolutely love
is you said uh if you had money and
somebody was stealing from you every day
you wouldn't let that keep happening yet
that's what happens with inflation
explain that a little bit in terms of
that it's just just such a concise
down-to-earth way to describe inflation
uh and so it seems to really resonate
with people
yes so inflation is the slow killer
uh of wealth and the best way i can
describe it is that
if you use the frog in the pot theory if
you put a frog in a
boiling pot of water if you turn the
heat up uh immediately
the frog will sense danger and jump out
right so anything that's going to be
done to your community won't be
overnight it'll be slow and gradual so
if you put the frog in that pot of water
and you turn it up slowly
and slowly and slowly by the time the
frog realizes it's too hot
he's already cooked and we've been
cooked with inflation
so to say over time and that inflation
has killed the purchasing power of the
black community
and sometimes people often say uh when
the u.s has a cold
the black community has a flu meaning
that if something's going wrong in
america
it's even worse in the black community
we saw that with a lot of the covid
numbers we see that with every tragedy
that happens it's even worse for us
so what inflation has done to our
community it has took your purchasing
power to where grandpa could have a job
and your grandmother could stay at home
you can still have a house and a car so
now you could have a two
income household and barely afford an
apartment with public transportation so
that's what inflation has done to our
money over time purchasing power has
decreased
and i want people to understand that the
only way to win against inflation is to
have your money
in an asset that beats out that
inflation year over year
and right now we're looking at 15 to 20
inflation rates
with the printing of money with more
coming i think they're announcing it
tomorrow
how will you win in this market how will
you preserve will well you have to have
an asset such as bitcoin which has
outperformed every other market
uh the guy on cnbc said he tells his
friends to invest in the s p
that's great but it made 16 last year
that's not keeping up with inflation
really
um bitcoin does and it beats it by a
large margin so
uh that's how you can preserve that
wealth and that's that's the point
you know i really want to get out to
people uh as i speak to them over time
absolutely when you talk to people and
you start educating them where they read
your book
and they say hey you know what i need to
actually get involved here
what's normally your recommendation or
how somebody from the black community
can get started in bitcoin
is there a certain site you want to send
them to is there's a way
whether it's dollar cost averaging or
something else like what's kind of the
first step that you normally tell
first thing i tell them yes three easy
steps buy it
store it earn it right so if you want to
get into
the industry you got to have skin in the
game so go ahead and buy some i always
say
before we even discuss it if you you
know one dollar worth
two dollars worth of ten dollars that's
available now so buy it
set up dollar cost averaging with either
you know cash apps one bitcoin
either manually in your head say i'm
going to do this monthly whatever
dollar cost average then store it move
it to a hardware wallet
you can move it to a paper wallet move
it to an external wallet
show people how to do that so that you
have bitcoin in your possession
no keys no cheese so if you don't
actually own it
you don't really own bitcoin you have a
bitcoin iou
and then once you have it secure you can
actually uh earn bitcoin so you can use
a service like
foldapp where you can spend the wheel
you get free stats every day
or earn stats back on visa purchases or
lolly
l-o-l-l-i if you have a spending problem
i buy way too much post mates but i get
three and a half percent back
in bitcoin every time the good thing
about that on lolly uh is there's other
stores as well thousands of stores
so you can earn bitcoin so you're not
just buying it so you're
on one hand dollar cost averaging you're
securing it and you're also earning it
daily
that's the best way to stack sets and if
you're not rich you don't have to be
because stacking sets is a way to to get
a percentage of a scarce supply
that is the goal so don't think about
the price just stack sas
i've heard uh not your keys not your
coins i've never heard no keys no cheese
but that might be
even better yeah exactly
and i think people get that i mean
especially when you talk about you know
owning something or actually in your
possession it's like
you're just it's just a crypto bank at
that point if you keep it on uh exchange
and
remember we're trying to have
self-sovereignty yeah
talk a little bit about just the
underbanked in america right my
understanding is that there's a pretty
big population especially in the black
community that is
under bank meaning that maybe they have
some version of a bank account or some
version
of financial services but they
definitely don't have everything that uh
maybe people on wall street would expect
them to have
and so something like bitcoin actually
can help close that gap
because really you just need an internet
connection right
yes and you know what's crazy is as
simple as that sounds
there's communities in america where
internet connections are a problem
and people didn't realize that until
everybody had to work from home and kids
had to go to school and they were like
you do realize there's communities where
our internet connection
we can't afford better than 25 megabits
per second which can barely get you
zoom calls so people don't understand
even that at a base level
in some communities is a barrier but
once you get over that because most
people do have phones
most people do have that way that is the
only barrier to entry is connection to
the internet and then once you have that
ability to connect that gives everybody
a a fair shake
at being banked because in the black
community we have almost 20 percent of
people
are unbanked we have money in the
mattress or
you have a cash based business black and
brown communities
where that happens that is something
where people thought if i hoard my cash
i'm saving i'm keeping it later
you have to understand that dollar is
getting less and less
in value every single day and like i
said before inflation is like getting
your door kicked in and getting robbed
every single day
you wouldn't take it after a while you
would find a solution and that solution
is to put it into assets or into uh
like some people have done public
treasuries uh put their public
treasuries into bitcoin that's what you
have to do so
save yourself um with that with that
strategy and
of course make sure if you are a
business do what you have to do uh to
preserve your wealth
you can't just let it go away with money
in the mattress or something your
grandmother told you about
not trusting banks uh bitcoin is not
that that's not
the same thing so this is a much much
different way
yeah and it's really funny because the
distrust is very real in some
communities in america right where
basically
i know in like the chinese-american
community also in the black community
there
there is a very very deep rooted uh
distrust in these institutions and so
really bitcoin serves in in some weird
way as the exact opposite where you can
basically get all the security and the
preservation of the purchasing power but
you get the sovereignty as well
so you kind of get the best of both
worlds mm-hmm yes and
you know it's it's so simple it's
complicated you tell people this and
they're like
wow so it really solves all the problems
we talked about yes it's
probably the greatest invention in a few
hundred years
uh but it's not seen that way it's just
like oh it's just something that
probably like no
it solved a lot of problems so you're
right it definitely is the best of both
worlds
gives you that security and uh you know
honestly for people who have never
invested bitcoin
it's probably the first thing most
people have invested in we've got a
whole new wave of investors just because
the barrier to entry was low for bitcoin
and cryptocurrency so
uh i love that about this industry
absolutely
uh before i let you go i got two more
questions for you first tell us about
the books uh you've got the first one
out
uh very popular uh you are probably the
only person i know
that got jack dorsey tweeting about uh
about your book which was
pretty cool um you've been on cnbc
recently and
it seems like people are really starting
to kind of pay attention talk about the
first book and then you've got a second
one that is on a pre-order
absolutely so the first book bitcoin in
black america
was written in 2019 and after
published um you know a lot of people
with the black community started to
realize that this was quote unquote for
us which was the message i wanted to get
out there the synergy between bitcoin
black community was great and i wanted
to make sure that we got the message
because it is for everybody but i
believe that the message had
you know at that time it went over a lot
of people's head it left a lot of
people with a sour taste in their mouth
after 2017 they didn't know what was
happening they thought the market was
crashing it was over
so that's why i put out bitcoin in black
america and that gives solutions such as
how to use it in the black church
uh in hbcus how to have blockchain
groups things of that nature
and other solutions uh as well in the
second version
i actually discuss the bitcoin and black
america tour
talking with black people all around the
country so that you can see that we are
still very early there are people who
did not know you could buy a fraction of
a bitcoin even up until 2020.
so you have to understand we're still
pretty early as as deep in the wormhole
as we
are still very early uh the second book
uh the second chapter sorry the herd is
coming
uh literally describes how we can
establish ourselves take it a step up
it's not just enough to own bitcoin you
need to know how to
have your own node you need to have a
private wallet you need to understand
the stock to flow model
you need to know why the continuing
effect why things are the way they are
and you need to understand that the herd
is coming means that institutions are
coming
the sense of urgency needs to be there
so that's the second chapter uh the
third one
everybody's favorite [ __ ] the banks uh
this is the second part of that but this
one
is literally only things that banks have
done
and the uh the hypocrisy they've shown
just in 2020.
this is just 2020. because last time you
know i put
it 2012 to 2019 stuff just to keep it
short i want people to realize this is
just last year this is why kova was
going on
why you thought everybody was asleep
they were manipulating markets
they were coming out the blue saying
bitcoin is going to be a hundred
thousand dollars when three years ago
it was the the worst asset ever so i
exposed all of that
uh the fourth chapter uh black is global
it actually describes
how around the world remittance payments
are great for the black community
because a lot of my friends are
nigerian they're haitian they're
jamaican remittance payments is a huge
industry
where if across borders they're starting
their industry you don't have to
necessarily quote unquote cash out
anymore
and the industry built built around that
the fifth chapter
one of my favorites uh bitcoin is
reparations it describes the need to
take reparations rather than ask for
them i'm not big on
saying hey can you pay us back for it
done before that that could take
decades if it's a bitcoin you have the
opportunity to take it
and i'm one of those people that i'm not
about to sit around and ask let's just
take it and do it our way
um next i talk about decentralized
finance the promise there
with uh being able to as we discussed
before collateralize
your crypto and taking away the
racial part of it forever uh and the
social economic part of it forever
and just focusing on the money aspect
and then the last chapter is called no
more talking because
seriously after this chapter there
should be no more talking it includes
dollar cost average strategies
it talks about uh the eight ways to earn
bitcoin without trading
uh you know other concepts i talk about
bitcoin in marriage
preserving it for generational wealth
what happened what happens in a divorce
uh what happens if you don't store your
keys for your children and your will
how to do all that stuff because people
need to start thinking you know your
bitcoin
the reason a lot of people's gonna be
lost is because of people dying it's not
gonna be because people lost keys people
gonna die and never
have stored their keys or taught their
family so i put all that in there so
that black people can actually enjoy
generational wealth
with bitcoin and that is all in the
second book uh there's also three
webinars attached to it
and this is one of the first books i
believe to introduce scarcity
there's only ten thousand books that
will ever be sold uh
hardcover all of these books for the
second edition and uh
this is a educational experience so when
you buy the book
you get the digital copy you get the
audio book you get the hardcover and you
get the webinar so
i want to make sure i hit home the sense
of urgency for the black community and
i'm pretty sure
nobody's ever done that before but i'm
not sure uh
so that that's the second book in the
nutshell i love it where can we send
people to go
pre-order it pre-order at bitcoin and
blackamerica.com
all right awesome we're definitely gonna
send people there last question i have
for you is sponsored by
eight sleep these guys built this
mattress that basically uh
cools you off so you can sleep deeper
and get better rem sleep
uh i've been sleeping on it and uh i
feel like a new man
what's your sleep schedule like are you
one of these people who sleeps ten hours
a night or are you operating on four or
five
oh man i'm about at two or three i have
a diaper
i have a two-month-old daughter and i
like to watch charts from 2 a.m to 6 a.m
during asian markets
so i don't have a sleep schedule uh my
mom thinks has always thought i was
weird
she was like you're the only person i
know that's a night person and a morning
person
it's like i don't even know where sleep
comes in but i'm a nap person you know i
take naps
i have to get my 30 minutes here hour
here but i'm up man
life is exciting i like to be awake zay
we gotta get you some sleep man that's
crazy
i got a i got a two-month-old daughter
too so that makes it worse so i
really don't get any sleep it's just you
know it is what it is but i
i definitely got my my tempurpedic back
there so i'm gonna start using it more
i love it i love it nah man well eight
sleep is fantastic tempur-pedic is great
as well
listen man i really really appreciate
you taking the uh the time to uh to jump
on here you're always high energy you've
got lots and lots of great information
and uh if anyone wants to go to
bitcoinblackamerica.com they can either
get
uh the first book or they can pre-order
the second book
all independently published uh basically
you're doing it all the right way so
thank you so much for doing this
and we will definitely do this again in
the future yes sir thank you for having
me palm
always good to talk with you congrats on
the marriage my brother